And the answer is the absolute value of x, and I can prove it to you.
If you were to show the absolute value of x, then it can't be anything negative.
And all the points here get moved from the negative side to the positive side.
So, this point in particular over here becomes this point here.
Gone are these.
This point over here becomes this point over here.
So this is how it looks like if you look near all the points to the absolute
value of X coordinate system.
You just flip them over.
And if you look at this diagram,
what you find is that there is now a beautiful, perfect linear separation.
And if you ask yourself, how did the linear separation look in
the original space of x and y is effectively something like that.
It is non-linear because it has this inflection point over here.
That's non-trivial to see, but
as you look at this, I hope you get that adding this one new non-linear feature
makes support vector machine linear separate the Xs from the circles.